all right guys how are you I am here
with Jim O'Shaughnessy an absolute
legend on on Wall Street he's laughing
as I say that which means that it's
probably true Jim thank you so much for
for joining us well I can tell you that
my wife and children say I am a legend
in my own mind that's half the battle
actually though I'm super excited to
have you I think you know a lot of times
we spend time talking with people who
are in the decentralization kind of
cryptocurrency industry and mindset you
have a very different background coming
from a long career on Wall Street in
traditional finance and so I'm excited
to hear what you kind of think about all
of this the hoopla and hype around
around crypto sure not glad to be here
so for those that don't know you why
don't we go through your background
first and then you can make it sound as
legendary as you'd like well actually I
came up as a young guy just I fell in
love with the stock market at an early
age that's kind of weird but I grew up
in st. Paul Minnesota and we had a
family foundation and they would once a
quarter have meetings for the foundation
in st. Paul and when I got to be old
enough they invited me to the dinners a
bunch Irish people you can imagine how
those dinners would go but I was
listening to my uncle and father argue
about the merits of IBM mhm and they
were talking all about whoever the
current CEO was then everything that
they were describing was people and I'm
like listening to this thinking I think
that that's an awful way to buy a public
company maybe if you're doing a start-up
the people matter a lot more but if
you're buying one of the biggest
companies in the world
I think numbers are mournful so I went
down to the James J Hill library which
was a great reference library in Saint
Paul all the railroad barons set up
these enormous libraries and so they
were they had everything originally I
grabbed the sp
tearsheet book which has 500 companies
in it and being potentially one of the
laziest people on the planet decided
that that was not going to work out for
me so I thought why don't I just look at
the 30 stocks in the Dow and so I found
a book the hair that went all the way
back to 1885 and it showed every single
component of the Dow from 1885 forward
and learned a lot of really interesting
things for example they kicked IBM out
of the Dow before it went up something
like 30 fold and they replaced it with
AT&T which went up 1 times so you know
had they left you know certain stocks in
the Dow the Dow would be vastly higher
today anyway what I did was I lists the
30 for each year and then I just did the
standard numbers price price to earnings
dividend yield price to book all of
those things and literally this is 1978
I had to do this by hand on a big paper
spreadsheet and so I I got an inkling
that not paying up for a stock was a
good way to invest I did a comparison
between the Dow stocks with the highest
piece verse the lowest P's and there was
no comparison
buying annually the ten with the lowest
p/e just absolutely obliterated the ten
highest p/e stocks but then I also
looked at dividend yield I ultimately
wrote an article for Barron's in 1993
you might be familiar with the famous
dogs of the Dow strategy well I took
that back to when the modern Dow was
created there were a couple of their
books so I do not claim credit for
having invented that strategy but the
other books only really went to the
1950s mmm-hmm and so I thought well you
know the Dow has been around since the
late 20s let's go see how it does and
we'll have this huge out-of-sample hold
out period to see whether it works then
as well it did and of course I'm an 18
year old male I had other interests
including girls and parties and all
those
so I kind of set that aside went to
college and then met my current wife of
36 years at a college summer party
graduated college and then started back
in earnest and now I had computers so
now I was really Damon and so I got
hired by a big pension fund in the Twin
Cities called control data it was an old
conglomerate and back then you know the
dark ages really were dark a lot of
people didn't even know what style their
portfolio manager was using were they
growth were they value where they growth
at a reasonable price you know all of
these things and they said we want you
to come in and make some sense of this
for us so I founded the company of
Shaughnessy Capital Management in 1987
to do that and we created what were
called normal portfolios they're like
highly specialized benchmarks it's not
like using the S&P 500 or using the
Russell 1 value you know as a kind of a
general benchmark for how manager might
be doing what we did was take the
manager's portfolios put them on a
database look at the most extreme
differences in their portfolio from that
universe and then use the most extreme
differences to screen the same universe
for a portfolio of stocks that looked
acted and most importantly performed
like the underlying manager the whole
purpose of a normal portfolio was really
simple it was is this manager through
his or her activity trading selling
buying adding any significant value to
their underlying stat style or is it all
the style hmm well what we found was my
kind of aha moment even though we
attributed huge transaction costs to the
portfolio's that we created as the
normals they killed their underlying
managers and I don't mean just by a
percent or two they absolutely destroyed
them why
because this was the inkling of I wonder
if that cartoon by Kelly is right Pogo
we've met the enemy and it's us and
that's when I started to develop the
theory that basically human beings are
designed to suck as investors right so
we are optimized towards a history that
no longer exists and hasn't existed in
eons right when we're out walking on the
Savannah and we see a bush rustling it's
a probably a very good idea to turn
around and run like hell right because
you don't know what that is it could be
a predator it could be something else
but you're not gonna take your chances
you're just gonna run well all of our
ancestors of everyone sitting in this
room ran so the ones who didn't run the
braver all got killed and so that that
made us optimized to be very very
fearful of perceived threats and so when
markets as we know are incredibly
volatile what do people do the amygdala
takes over the fear takes over the brain
and there's almost nothing you can do to
fight it unless you are a quantitative
investor who does not override their
model right so I started reading a lot
of what is now known as behavioral
finance and actually I found a book by a
guy by the name of Robin Dawes Britt who
his book was actually about
psychotherapy but he had a great chapter
about all of the studies that had been
done over actuarial outcomes ie
algorithmic outcomes and clinical
outcomes that means I'm the doctor
diagnosing you and when they started all
these things in the 50s they all thought
all of the researchers thought that the
human expert was going to soar above
these simple algorithmic solutions the
algorithmic solutions destroyed them and
they destroyed them for one reason and
one reason only they were consistently
applied
time and time and time again we humans
are far more interesting right we get
hung over we have a fight with our
spouse we're in a bad mood or we're in a
good mood and we let that influence our
decisions in financial markets you know
there's a study that just sticks out in
my mind and that is about people trying
to get parole if you want to get per
mole per roll make sure that you are one
of the first appointments of the day the
people who are at the you know the eight
to ten in their hearing they get parole
at at something like eighty five percent
of the time
guess who almost never gets paroled the
people whose appointment is right before
lunch and why is that the judges are
hungry and so they're like nope nope
nope time for lunch
and you know it's amazing
but I've collected these examples over
the years and you know I often say to
people we have known about this for a
long long time one of the best books
that I think every new investor should
read is reminiscence of a stock operator
the fictionalized life of Jesse
Livermore who was a big trader back in
the 20s and literally was short the
market going into the 1929 crash people
he had higher security guards because
people wanted to tear him limb from limb
because again if you understand human
history if you understand human
psychology we all look for a scapegoat
we had very famous scapegoats during the
financial crisis right and that hasn't
changed at all and so he had to go into
hiding and ultimately the real sadness
of Livermore is he ended up killing
himself in the sherry Lehmann hotel here
in New York because he finally had that
last trade which bankrupted him and even
though he knew right and his whole book
reminiscence of a stock operator is all
about nothing ever changes the same
thing that led Isaac Newton to buy in at
the top of the South Sea trading company
back in the 1700s is happening to us
so I always say different play or sorry
different players same play yep